This is called Eagle. Cad this is a PCb layout software currently, this [is] the
The latest variant design for the [Srf] are tiny little radio, so this is how I?
go from an idea of let's put these electrical components together to
Let's build an actual radio we usually prototype
We get a prototype panel made in the uk
Hence most of the little green stuff [will] build one or two test it once we're happy with the design we will go to China
To get the Pcbs manufactured we end up with empty PCb boards like this totally we get those done in China
but we've then populate that here in the uk in the back room, so
[we're] in the
Lawson Clean Tech center, and this is our back workshop, and this is our pick-and-place machine
which is just about ready to do a run pick and place machine picks up all the
microscopic Tiny Little components
[alright] a 5 capacitors resistors
Fixed more places them on the board
To save us having to do it with tweezers because it takes too long, and then we go and stick it through the oven
Melt the solder cooks it and out of that. We get a finished product tucked in the shaft here is our little oven that
We use to cook up products that's flashing oils that all that is it doing what it's waiting for one?
It's currently on a preheat ready
maintaining this temperature it sits at around
150 degrees C. And then when it cooks it raises up to about 220 degrees C. We should start beginning
With the blank boards and the solder paste and go through Step-by-step
These are some of the PCB panels we get back from China we get different
Sized panels depend on how [many] we can squeeze on there and what size we're looking at production time
So [we've] got 24 on there 15 on there
six
Four of those or sometimes we even get the made individually if they're quite a big board
so we get panels from China in various sizes and then we take them over to the
stencil printer and add Solder paste that will take a
Fresh PCB
line up from the Stencil printer
And we have adjustment dials to line up
and and then we squeegee on
Solder paste
miss that bit
this Stencil put solder paste on the area where the
components are going to sit where we want to solder where we want to fix leds or resistors and chips and
then we have a pasted board next we're going to insert this and put it in a pick and place machine, so we
Take our pasted boards and put them inside our picking place, and you see we've already got three lined up and ready to go sometimes
We'll just have a full panel
sometimes like this, we'll put
Three [in] [it] once main working better the pick [and] place these we call feeders these are plug-and-play feeders
This one has leds mounted on it in a real
it looks like [an] [old] tape reel you know audio tape or something it is tape you have a
pocket the
Components sitting and a cover tape that holds the components in and you can see there's an exposed component at the point here
That's an led so we have
feeders for a range of size components mostly the small stuff
Room for a few bigger ones over here. We also have a tray full of ICs three to eight chips
Where your arduino processor chips the machine itself has a movable
x my
Head with a pickup nozzle. It's a very nice robot and
These are the different [size] nozzles for picking up different components. We have two vision cameras, but the machine uses to
Look at parts as it's moving around the check alignment of stuff is a program that tells it where to place all the components
Of vision analysis window showing you what it's looking at as it places components
And some of the controls this is going to go away and build
three Pi lights if I hit the button
It's already knows where everything is so the first thing that started is load up ahead
And it's picking a component having a look placing it pick up component. Have a look place it
So every time it pauses over that white ring in the middle
takes a picture
and those [vision] analysis
to work out the
X of y offset and the rotation of a cone [of] these picked up and it aims to pick up the component in the center
But there's no guarantee. It's going to pick up a component exactly in the center
so it looks at the other side of the component and works out a
Ex-wife correction in relation to this crosshairs that it's drawn when it then places the component
It applies that correction offset so [that] it [makes] sure the component goes exactly where it's supposed to be
3 Pi lights will take this machining around about 15 minutes
Different boards take different amount of time depend on how many components there are how many panels are in there at once how many pieces?
So the picking place is just finished doing [its] [15-minute] run I can go and pick a component and view where thinks it's put it
Looking through with occurrences placed checking the position of just a few of the random components and see where it's placed
The components are pushed into the solder paste, [so] they are reasonably well stuck. I'm not gonna
go very far, but [we] still a little careful, so
We can place a pit board in the oven
Clothes [are] [up]
wait for it to hit temperature and
Say going that's Gonna
Take about five minutes to cook a board during which time it will heat up
reflow the solder paste [keep] it warm for a little while, and then cool it down out of the oven we get a
Snackie finish [boards]
will take over testing and programming to program these boards and
fish to use an Arduino base texture, so
an Arduino
the Prototype shield on top take Freshly cool board
Flip it on the little Jig press the button
Load some code I
Don't [runs] tested this
No, yeah, the pilot has the Adreno three to a chip on there running some code which takes
Text over the serial port and displays it
Running on the raspberry Pi is a python sketch that it's basically monitoring my Twitter feed anyone. I follow on Twitter
when they tweet that [python] sketch pulls that tweet down and
Pushes it out over the serial port to the [pilot] which then scrolls the techs across the Led Matrix
This is a chunk of the Arduino sketch
That's running actually on the [pi] light on the throw to [a] chip monitoring the serial port [and] carrying those characters into the font
and outputting across the
126 leds on the other half of the screen here is the
[python] Sketch, Which is
monitoring the Twitter feed over the network cable and and
Pushing that back out to the pilot all of this is running on the pI completely standalone from my computer
[yeah], I mean you can take that plug in a wi-Fi dongle and plug it in elsewhere and away you go
If you have access [to] those kind of infrastructures guy here
Just goes [tap] tap two short dots for two zeros and the guy at Reno knows for only
$2,000 it is sunny disrupt
Anything this normal life [in] a particular country